what's good good people derek jackson
here so i was looking at the comments
from a previous live chat and i saw a
woman ask a question of
you know why is it that as women y'all
give your all to a man for years on end
you contribute so much value to his life
but when the relationship doesn't work
out it's like a couple of months later
he's in a new relationship and he's
giving that new woman
everything that you are asking for i
mean he's just done a complete
turnaround
let me say this i understand a lot of
y'all get told things like well he must
have been trashed from the beginning or
just move on but it's not that simple
you know when you are picking up the
pieces to your heart it's just not that
easy to look at another woman getting
the entire world handed to her
on a silver platter and there are some
reasons for that but first let me just
clear up the fact that yes
men can improve and grow from one season
of their life into another one you know
hindsight is 20 20 they can learn from
their mistakes
but if you understand that and something
still don't sit right with you about how
things have gone in your previous
relationship or
maybe it's happened a couple of times
one of those reasons may be
that the god is is moving on into that
new relationship with that new woman
and he's using this stellar way that
he's treating her
as a subliminal message to you that you
were the problem even if you weren't
i did not see that coming hold up
subliminal message i feel like derek
jackson
is tapping into the ghost of the bitter
and just saying
what she would say derek is the ghost of
the better
that's what that's what derek is derek
is the ghost of the bitter
he's who did you see she has a new car
look at that house the house look better
than
maybe he's just trying to send you a
message he's still thinking about you
oh payback is a [ __ ]
oh man you know what's crazy about this
video from there
is he started off decent huh
i was like oh my god i was oh oh he's
okay derek he's making six i was like
he's making
sense what the [ __ ]
what the making sense um and then
secondly
a lot of times when the guy realizes
that you're no longer paying him any
attention so he's no longer able to send
a message to you because your ears are
closed your eyes are closed you're not
really worried about him
a lot of guys meet their karma you know
now they're with a woman
and they're maybe even in a marriage
with this woman
and now she's for everybody what do you
mean she's she for everybody
i don't know what i mean me calling up i
thought it was about
lifting them up maybe i'm wrong another
reason this guy's
genuinely sorry about what he did to you
and now he's trying to rid himself of
his guilty conscience that he has about
it
you know when a guy is the problem and
you leave him especially
a lot of times what happened is he's
going to have all of those thoughts and
memories of all the things you were
asking he just wished that he could turn
back the hands of tom
turn back the hands of tom you know but
if i can't do that then he'll go out
unfortunately
[Laughter]
no
if i could turn
for instance if she's built on
validation but you are built on love
there's going to be a lot more peace in
their home when in reality
you know she's got lower standards so
yeah it's a lot easier
i know uplift the bash bash the uplift
you ask one woman to uplift the other
yeah
it's all good yeah jackson because
nobody's that other woman who just got
the guy
everyone's the woman who got robbed and
so he knows who his
is meanwhile she's good
with an instagram post she's she's
pacified by some money being spent on
her buy a new bag a new purse a new trip
a new something like that and you know
and that's just a matter of you being a
top tier cream of the crop woman
and i'm not saying that to gash you up
and i'm not saying it to be judgmental
to other people
which is just that's what you just did i
do believe that yes we are all created
equal but we don't all move equal
i'ma say this once
one time one time one time
derrick jackson is killing you softly
darry
jackson is basically what he what he's
doing is that he's giving you fuel
for you to ha it's like it's fueling
your resentment
and he's fueling your anger for you oh
yeah that's why he ain't
he like this because that's his
demographic women
that are miserable and by keeping you
miserable
he's got more money more problems but
more money and he's able to do this
seminars and stuff like that
and that's what it is gaslighting you
and all of that
for you to stay miserable and resent
that dude
and giving you false ideas on that dude
yo
derek jackson is to steve harvey
what darth vader is to darth sidious
he's the apprentice yes yes but he's
about to overtake the mess
definitely definitely yeah darth
simpious
darth simpson that's my new nickname for
derek darth simpson yeah
yeah and with that being said you know
if if he's only built to excel in the
playground
he's going to do a whole lot better with
the monkey bars and the swings and
you know the merry-go-round that he's
going to do with a woman like you who's
built on business who's built on
breaking generational curses of
continued dysfunction
who's built on building a empire and
legacy you can't do that with somebody
who can only excel when it's play play
time i
play play pause i never tell them to
halt
stop cause i drop and roll
with the truth hot
they're calling the streets sizzling
like who sizzler
boom boom
my mom said what did you say say i said
i ain't trying to get no beating though
oh god damn she said
you gonna get that beating though oh
and i'm like damn i just wanted to play
play but you know what they say say
what they say never mess with mama
because today's her day date
i came for the fans oh came for him
battle reps
let's go i came with some hams okay
thanksgiving
yes go we here with some lambs listen
but we are getting slaughtered look hey
boy
mm-hmm you know what time it is what
time is it
play play oh
goddamn that was how that made no sense
i made it that was hot
that was high that playing
hmm don't play with me bro bars so hot
they stinky
yes all right okay all right now that
we're done trolling because this is
stupid at least you know here's the
thing right
go ahead please derek has these ladies
ears right
and i think oftentimes when it comes to
these kind of difficult situations
people are hurt
people are trying to understand and so
there's an opportunity for you someone
who's trusted by these people
to give them all the possibilities i'm
not saying the possibilities that you
laid out aren't possible
but to choose them as the first example
is ridiculous it's like this right
if i call you we go on a couple dates
and then i never call you back
and then you start asking your friends
why didn't abba call me back you trash
cuz he did not
value you because your value therefore
he did not
value value my thing is why would you go
to the most extreme
possibilities as an explanation for what
right
the friend wouldn't go to the ground and
be like the reason why abbott didn't
call you
because that nigga's working with isis
right he a terrorist
right like you wouldn't say that you
would go to the most logical he's just
not that into you
and it's okay it hurts it doesn't make
you feel great
but it's probably going to be the truth
but it is why derek seems so
disingenuous
and i think why he rubs a lot of dudes
the wrong way it's not because he's
giving you ladies a lot of info
i think talk to the ladies go ahead
but when you lie because it makes you
money when you
you know have all this influence over
people and you're just saying this kind
of stuff to make them feel better
it makes me look at you as a person with
no character
and that's fine but when you're in a
position of authority or a position of
like
leadership where you're giving people
advice and you're acting like you're the
the know it all right the guru it makes
me disappointed that people believe in
someone with so little
character and integrity that's all it is
this is ridiculous
so he's treating the next person the
next better right there's a plethora of
reasons why it may be possible but the
most likely one is
he's more into that person than he
wasn't to you or he just grew
i don't know and that that relationship
that you had with him
made him learn something and it's not
fair
you know it's not nice to be the person
who's always going to be the one that
helps build up men
for the next person yeah but you know
what my ex's helped build me up
my exes became better after they dated
me as well that happens
we are all part of each other's growth
you're just not that person for him
and what you need to do is instead of
checking his instagram to go see all the
updates
block it move on with your life
concentrate on you
why are you out here checking these
updates it's not fair it's not right it
hurts
why would you go out to need to sleep
cause yourself pain
i don't know maybe it's just me maybe i
said some stuff that sounds crazy
but these are my thoughts derek is
disappointing as usual
today he went extra extras but you know
yeah that's just that i said what i said
you just is the demographic is
immeasurable women yeah
and when you have a plant you water it
if it's a miserable plant you water that
measurable plant for the miserable to
grow
and that's what he does and that's what
happens and then you know so that's all
we got for today's uh
topic yeah tell us what you guys think
we want to hear you guys in the comments
[Music]
below
oh that's it boy you sipping yeah
boy you sipping okay but oh boy you
tripping okay
why why tell him why is he oh the line
okay
these ladies in these streets like oh my
god derek that [ __ ]
but i'm saying hey did he make you
bigger nope
what do you do belittle me better
belittle you better but literally you
fetter but little
cheddar get some little cheddar make a
ring
sprinkle girl you never gonna know no
pain i know girl because i'm here to
cuddle you oh
no you're not cuddle you smile uh no get
in these sheets girl
uh who are you talking to what oh
no we're not all created equal but we
don't all
move equal because we're all equally
moving through these planes
and as i'm on a plane to a better plane
i inform you that you have been informed
knowledge is knowing knowing that you
know the knowledge
is all seeing knowing i see the knowing
the no sees me but i never say no
to the scene that's got to be seen
can you see the scene that i've painted
for the
theme theme
i could turn
i would never do that because time is an
illusion
boy i've made an intrusion in your mind
as i'm dropping these beats
like beats by dre but i never get played
like dre
by my ex-wife cause she's a queen
see see the scenes
green
[Music]
a time